a modern-day church we we need our own
uh her Builders here in America what do
you
think yeah me
too our next speaker could not be here
in person but he so strongly believes in
the cause of Freedom that he comes to us
via video link he is a man who is
unafraid to stand for principles that
the political and media Elites would
prefer to sweep under the rug here is a
man who went into the world's foremost
hotbed of anti-American anti-freedom
sentiment the United Nations boo um that
Collective of negate the negation of
humanity and stood fearlessly and
unflinching unflinchingly for justice
and human dignity here is a man who
faced down accomplished prati
practitioners of violent intimidation
enemies of freedom apologists for
authoritarianism and total arianism and
stealth jihadists here is the rarest of
things in the Public Square today a
genuine sincere articulate and
accomplished lover of
America an American who is proud a proud
American and who knows why America is
the greatest country on
Earth and he's unafraid to say so even
in the most anti-American place you know
with the most American anti-American
haters on the planet um my fellow
Americans
and all those who appreciate and admire
his courage um I bring to you who I hope
may very well be the next president of
the United States Ambassador John
Bolton it's a great pleasure to be with
you today even if only remotely uh
obviously our main purpose is to pay
tribute to the victims of the 911
attacks and their families uh like all
of you I remember that day vividly I was
in the state department in me ings when
we heard of the attacks here in New York
City I went down to my office on the
seventh floor of the state department to
try and find out what had happened and
somebody rushed in and said an airplane
has crashed into the Pentagon I looked
out my window I could see the flames and
the smoke coming from the Pentagon and
it was a very Vivid
manifestation that America was under
attack uh I think we all also remember
remember the passengers and crew of
United Flight
93 uh who in many respects were the only
opportunity the victims of 911 had to
Counterattack uh they didn't need the
government to tell them what they do
what to do they didn't need politicians
to tell them what to do uh they didn't
need opinion leaders to tell them what
to do they knew what to do and they did
the right thing there on United FL
93 uh and I think as we remember and
honor the victims and the uh families uh
of the 911 tragedy uh it's with with
that in mind that we have to view uh the
proposal to build the ground zero mosque
it's a very strange Enterprise that says
we want to increase religious tolerance
and understanding uh and if you don't
agree with that we're going to increase
religious in tolerance and understanding
whether you like it or not uh that's
really a very unappealing face to put on
uh the supposed effort behind the mosque
uh and as well to look at the proponents
of the mosque and what they've said uh
Imam R who has said that the United
States was an accessory to
911 that uh Osama Bin Laden was made in
the USA
that the United States has more blood on
its hands than the terrorists themselves
and the Imam has refus to call Hamas a
terrorist organization uh I think that
all of this demonstrates that uh people
are entirely justified in raising
questions what the true motives of the
mosque's proponents are and if there's
an effort uh really at bottom with
people of Good Will to increase
religious tolerance and understanding
then a way can be found to do that that
doesn't cause the emotional pain uh that
this particular location proposed for
the mosque uh has aroused now beyond
that uh let's come to the paretic Imam
rou himself who in the midst of this
extraordinary crisis over his uh efforts
can't seem to find time in his busy
schedule
to come back to the United States uh to
address the critics and answer in a
transparent way exactly what his motives
are he is in fact traveling the world uh
at our
expense uh as a uh paid spokesman for
the state department sent around the
world uh to explain our country to other
people not withstanding the radical and
extreme statements that he's made so
even beyond the MOs controversy even if
a new location can be found uh I think
we need to have a serious conversation
about what it is that the state
department that has motivated them to
finance uh the Imam and perhaps others
like him you know Margaret Thatcher was
once uh said to have commented that in
her cabinet looking at the ministries of
the British cabinet that the agriculture
Ministry was there for the farmers and
the labor Ministry was there for the
trade unions uh and the foreign office
was there to represent the foreigners uh
we could ask what the thinking of the
state department is that has allowed
this kind of program to go forward I
think it's a plus for uh Americans to be
sent overseas to show other nations our
diversity that we have a functioning
democracy but that doesn't mean that our
tax dollars should be subsidizing uh
radicals making the kinds of statements
that Imam Ralph has made so there are a
lot of issues that have been raised by
this I think it's an important subject
of public debate uh I'm honored to have
been uh allowed to take part in it and I
think now we want to return to the theme
that has brought everybody together
today to remember the victims of 911 and
their families and to remember our brave
men and women in the American Military
who have protected us before and after
9/11 thinking of the sacrifices they
have made and that their families have
made as well thank you very much